[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge here in st. Louis for their
2017 winter chess classic hello chess
fans it's day four round four of the
2017 winter chess classic after three
rounds so far in Group A David Howell of
England leads the pack and in Group B
Kirill ax and bearish bullets share the
lead these players will earn top level
tournament experience but also there's a
twenty-thousand-dollar prize fund at
stake the winner of group a Mets five
thousand dollars the winner of Group B
that's four thousand dollars all right
round for Alexander eep atop the
Grandmaster who's going into slough
today he had a victory with the white
pieces over yarrow zero book a upcoming
US Championship competitor so Alexander
take us through the game and show us
this victory right and before us look at
the game I would like to say that I've
been knowing y'all off since early
childhood because we are from the same
sit in Ukraine and we know each other
since we were seven years old this was
like the Ukrainian Derby all the way to
present different situation very cool
yeah so yesterday I was quite
disappointed with my gay against Jeffrey
I was winning but it was a draw he found
a perpetual so i was a bit tired i
didn't want to prefer for this game I
didn't want to prepare something against
the Nanyan Kings Indian so here I mean
my ideas were like to play ex9 coin f4
and start checking and even maybe
pushing this one forever or maybe
Quantic physics and then 96 of kinetics
check and here we were in who are in a
heavy time trouble and you know it
definitely made some mistakes here
during the game I thought maybe she he
should have played they should be five
taken 26 squander control also if i push
East East em I mean be a square the
square from promotion is controlled by
the bishop attend but anyways I can play
East 6 and then they days when X 4 25
check I don't know
this should be turkey plate let's play
26 here i had i think two minute audio
one minute when i played my next book i
consider only the most esox with the
idea to bring the coin over 2f 424 and
then maybe 25 or 27 or cuenta
significant effects here yaar played 25
you before he played I also thought that
the unlink there was only moved but
according to chat 24 that I looked
briefly at this is just losing of dynamo
for King h6 and yarrow said that she saw
this no but the reason he didn't play it
the solution is to be checked more
deeply according to chat 2400 you know
but I have a feeling that white is
attacking here and this might be winning
I don't know because there are no checks
at the white pink and white has a lot of
ideas here I don't know but maybe so
it's just a joy to know but at the
25-lap late 90s you know revealed that
90 signals also winning because if King
age 6 27 this what he said I don't know
maybe toast one and then Mike win a
straight and just Quinn g7 I think take
yeah and it's just a thing okay should
be 95 I guess at this point miss I
didn't see I paid 98 my idea was to keep
late King 86 I want to play coy netflix
I don't know just because I thought them
and he cannot take because it takes a
fiction I promote the quince because his
piece is that too far too far away from
my aesthetic response and his King
cannot help because the way the juice
expand borders the blocking to come to a
sequin them safe sound and after Queen
Africa didn't see what like good that if
Quinn f3 check Quint except three then I
consider something I thought I can also
the solution for sure because i have a
lot of checks on dark squares when h 4
27
well known on h4 but if once you five
then white twin I think this is what I
sell so they're connected six winning
yeah i think this yeah what that was
what I so during the game you have
explained with 96 let my opponent plate
King f8 and 96 and it looks too good for
white so g5 I think my plant forgot that
up in the Queen takes f 3 i'm not forced
to go into this line
maybe he missed he missed the time of
order i don't have to go into that I
mean I that can simply play an IG 8 and
this is just made him to King h5 cornish
work I don't know because I mean when I
trade quite tempting connection on
there's also a CH four and twenty Sonya
I don't know what he missed maybe he
shows it sometime trouble I thing an
inch worth of the winning just automate
into if i'm not mistaken i think it's
all yeah and in time tribal anything in
heaven look if I GFI but here it was
really clear that I will be able to
optically a few checks and then get
extra 30 minutes and find the one
because I was sure the solution
completely winning because black doesn't
sure than any chick and I have a lot of
ideas like wen Shi Jie for here is
another idea in the game I played 28 and
wondered when the heroes I'm because of
kingi 697 and we can issue the 95 check
but that's another idea 93 I was also
considering it was not support them in
what they found was just like Astros
enemy deity but here i also met some
nice line where we change when maybe
that like this it's 95 and black hedging
instrument i think that the land Quint
XD 6h takes you six neck 6161 e6 they
should be to an a for thinking what i
thought they fixed sponsors promotion
pick one like i said we should be five
antechinus yeah that was quite quite
nice line but suppose not to force the
black had some other choices what I
plate it was just every single source
check check check and yeah winning the
quince yeah what I think today I was at
some point like oh we're pushed and
maybe I should have just punished like
against for the safe and round two Mike
one plate
defending game but in time trouble here
she made a mistake cyclist well with
work well when you play a good friend
like yarrow does that fundamentally
change how you play the game oh it's
difficult for me to play against friends
and for sure because then I've tried
most of them I know since the early
childhood I know how they slay me none
of their cell we shared some different
moments together and I don't have that
much fighting spirit against my friend
but in this tournament I I had to play
for one right because I have a round two
and they miss Winson around monstrous
now right after this tournament you say
you're going home to Turkey correct yeah
now you're going to be you've been
accepted to salou that's right are you
excited about moving here to the states
for the big powerhouse team of course
definitely I just being inside to save
fluid an opportunity and in San Luis is
a double inversion table so right now
after four rounds you have two points
how do you evaluate your performance so
far in the event well as I said I lost
in her own sister against to the Sabbath
was a horrible game entered his
preparation and Ellen preferred i went
to the complications and I should have
checked that the line is deeper but I
didn't deny God punished quite I deserve
certificated three punishing that game
was announced ones and entrails I bet
quite good games as black beans David
Howell and Jeffrey shanks I was a who's
winning in both of them but in time
trouble I made mistakes that's when I
had one up two minutes on the clock and
and yeah but today I want but I didn't
deserve so I mean when I deserve I
didn't win but when I didn't deserve i
won no it's for it's like Barcelona
against PSG and champions like my
biggest one right yeah 61 is its sport
that's that's very you can say about
yeah well Grandmaster keep itself and
granulations today I guess let's check
out pardon me let's take a look at how
the rest of group a is doing after four
rounds of play with David Howell drawing
today in Group A he maintains his sole
lead at three out of four points on
Wednesday March fifteenth round five
group a game of the day has got to be
David Howell with the black pieces
taking on Emilio Cordova it's been a
long day in Group B for this man
Grandmaster Francesco Rambaldi plane for
Italy he took on Grand Master action
shandra the 2015 Junior close champion
this game went well over 100 moves you
had the white pieces take us through
your victory here sure and so we got
this position well I have a strong
attack but I don't know if it's enough
for compensation but my opponent really
had like very little time like one
minute and he played King a shape which
is a losing move and I'll clean HIV has
to give the cream of Queen g6 he
probably intended to play h6 that's
after esox cutting off the Queen I'm
just mating so he played Queen g6 and
here white should be just winning I mean
there's some play with the bishops
shouldn't be a problem I saybrook us one
because if I can just trade a pair of
books and even if I'm losing an exchange
also be winning but here on move 40 we
got this position I just played H Phi
which is a very bad move I'm completely
missed his idea that they will keep
Ricky to and rookie for which is very
strong if I had just say Queen up free i
think i'd probably be just winning so
instead we got this very complicated
position all it was very interesting but
I wasn't very happy to have it since I
was winning if you moved earlier I
really don't know how well we play here
here we go he I gave my king pythons for
the d5 pawn and then we should be sphere
we I mean this position I really don't
know what is going on is just very
complicated
here I thought he would play rugby too I
thought this was a better try but not he
played rook da time here I can he allows
me to exchange a pair of books weblog
age three and so this was already good
because my kink is a lot safer now but
it's so unclear how I should if the
position is winning and how I shouldn't
if it is because he has a lot of counter
play ya hear I think this moves are
correct and left he found this idea
Bishop b2 Bishop before which is very
strong just I think it's the only way to
prevent me from cleaning coupons and the
point is I cannot say queen of seven and
e7 because he has a professional they
can can't get away so I played e7 this
Bishop takes there's a nice little maid
here I think I guess so can I take the
pond he had to play would be one you can
get to Bishop e7 Queen us for King g7 so
now my my king is not fear and I can use
it on the other hand I also lost one of
my past haunts 27 and here he he could
have played king of seven but I think
after Queen to e5 it's going to take a
long time but the position should be
winning I think and sunny day for takes
d5 so he's sacrificing the bishop but he
has sort of a fortress so like in this
position his it's hard for white to make
progress I really had to force him to
move the world from s5 otherwise i can
bring my king and i think this is a
critical moment because maybe King
Jake's was a better try I don't know if
the position is winning or if it's a
draw but I think this was a better try
because in the game
which doesn't stop here though alright
so the full disclaimer here we had some
real a issues with the move part of the
game had a player moving in to check
that did not happen so we're going to
switch viewers here skip a little bit
ahead in time and see how he wants yeah
so yeah so I was able to force his work
away and now he has to play g5 because
his rook being far away from his khengi
he may lose it if he like goes to seven
Frank green d7 what wind work if he goes
to h5 Queenie to win the rogue so he has
to push the pond and now the physician
should be winning because he can't
simultaneously defend both arms with a
rope with the work while keeping it
defended so you can defend both but the
work he may lose rook and so here I
think a better try was worked before and
I wasn't entirely sure what to do but i
think the position should be winning
instead King g6 I well the point is I
can't take the pot immediately because
of work at five but I can give a check
first and then take and not the
positions just when the rest of the game
was not right well congratulations on a
victory over the always game action
genre what do you make of your
performance so far in the winter classic
well it's been very shaky I played some
strange game some games I was worse than
I one or two and some games the third
round that was clearly better after the
opening and ended up losing so
there were it was a bit strange I guess
I haven't been saying very well even
today I allowed I mean I mean the game
lasted like 60 moves longer than it
should have but overall the result is
positive so that's good we've been
talking to a lot of slow guys in this
tournament you being one of them of
course so I know it's SlOO SlOO SlOO on
these recaps with that's just how it is
what's your experience playing with all
of these teammates in this winter
classic well fortunately only well I'll
be playing not only my my teammates both
our head coach I'm handling the right
seven from right how hungry so that that
will be interesting I mean over the
board it will just be a normal game so I
guess I'll have to change a few things
in my opening repertoire but apart from
that better everything will be normal
well congratulations once again let's
take a look after four rounds of play
the standings in Group B well today
gorilla drew while bars pullets won his
game so Andre bearish pullets takes
clear lead in Group E with three and a
half out of four Andre should be in the
game to watch tomorrow as he takes the
black pieces against alejandro ramirez
the 2017 winter chess classic runs every
day through sunday March 19th rounds
begin at one p.m. each day except for
the final round see the games live as
they happen on us chess champ calm and
chest 24.com